the Pentagon recently released a survey
showing that 8 out of 10 Young Americans
are ineligible to enlist in the military
primarily due to issues of obesity
physical and mental health issues
criminal records and so on so if 80
percent of young people aren't eligible
to enlist I mean that in itself shows a
sort of significant cultural Decline and
we seem to not be as interested in
what's going on with with young people
if we are to go to into enter some kind
of conflict with Russia or any other
country whether to support Ukraine or or
anyone else it seems that we should be
focusing on what has happened to young
people and instead we'd rather talk
about body positivity and some of the
other issues that Lyle points out